Basic requirements to start your own pig
farm. That will be the subject of
today's video. All right guys, it's a
beautiful moment right here. If you're
new to this channel, please ensure you
subscribe to this channel. Lots of great
content on profitable pig farming will
be made available to you. All right,
let's start off quickly. What are the
basic requirement for you to start your
own pig farm? Now, number one, you need
to have a space to keep them. That's
basic. Uh you you wouldn't keep your
animals. Of course, people run the
extensive system, but I would advise you
make use of the intensive because it's
far more better than the the extensive
system because pigs are fatty animals.
So, you don't want your animals running
all over the place. They would obviously
lose lots of u energy and fat in the
process. So, you want to ensure you keep
them in an intensive system. So, one of
the basic requirement is for you to have
a space to keep them. And for you to
build that space, one of the uh
important thing you need to have is a
fit trough. Of course, some people drop
their feet on the ground like but I
would not advise you run that all the
time. I think it be good for you to have
like a trough a feeding trough. It could
be as big as this. It could be smaller
than this. Anyh how you decide to do it.
Uh works well as long as you can easily
put their feeds in there conveniently
and they can feed as they want. So
that's one of the basic. Make sure you
have a feeding trough for them. And then
also ensure you make their ground the
the flooring very solid because these
guys are very destructive animals. If
you have not if you have not heard that
before, please quickly know this. These
guys can dig almost anything. Once they
get a a an avenue into the the hole,
they keep they keep on digging. So you
want to make sure you spend on quality
materials for the flooring. That's one
of the basic requirements you need. Make
sure the flooring is very solid. Don't
use too cheap material. Don't economize
on that. Make a very solid flooring. So
that's one of the other basic
requirement you need to ensure that uh
your animals are uh going to be all
right and ensure that your farm will be
good to go. Now you also need uh a way
to give them water. Now there are
different ways to go about that. Of
course we in this pen right here, we're
making use of this innovative way. But
uh that's an alternative also. The
trough you see there, one is actually
meant for food, the other is meant for
water. Now, this is like a deprecated
system. Not too many people are using
this system anymore where uh you are in
short that serves not just as the water
trough, but also as the wallow. I'm
talking about this uh on trough right
here. It also serve as the wall. But not
many people are embibing this system
anymore. The the modern way now is to
make use of the shower system. the O
system where you make use of O
uh like this make use of O like this to
uh to spray the animals. You could get
better one to spray the animals and
after spraying the animals the because
one of the main reason why you have the
wild system is because these guys are
special animals that means they that
means they don't have sweat paws. So
they are special in the way in that
sense their body doesn't have sweat
paws. So whenever it's quite hot like a
a situation like this. If you look right
here, you can see what this guy is
doing. You can see how this guy is
sleeping inside the water, that's
because it's trying to find a way to
cool off the body. So because of that
unique character unique characteristics
of pigs, you have to make uh uh an
avenue for them to be able to cool their
body. And uh if you're not going to do
the wall system, as I told you already
is deprecated, you can also uh make use
of the host. That means at a certain
interval during the day, you will just
uh take the O and spray the animals
that's being used. Whichever one works
for you. Some other people make use of
the automated shower system or even the
manual shower system where right on the
top they fix uh the shower right on the
top of their pen. They fix the shower
there and they can switch there will be
a switch where you can switch on the
shower. the shower falls and uh when the
shower is done at a point some people do
some automated one where it comes at a
certain moment in the day maybe in the
afternoon maybe by 12:00 the shower will
on for probably all depends that of
course it's a modern world right now so
lots of great innovations out there now
but uh some people do the manual one
where you just switch the shower on and
it pours uh out for them that's of
course all those things I talk about are
quite expensive so depending on your
budget you can decide on which want to
use. So some people actually just make
use of um the water paint. That means
they use like a paint to just like a
water container to just wet them with
bowls. So that's another way people do
it. So people use different means. So
but you know some of these means are
much more uh uh tedious than the other
ones. So whichever one works for you,
make sure you uh embibbe that. So one of
the other basic requirement that we
advise you to have on your farm is a
water tank and there's a very big need
for you to have this because these
animals are are animals that have uh
good they they use water a lot. Um pigs
are animals that water is a basic
requirement for them. So, you want to
ensure you have a water tank depending
on whatever capacity depending on the
farm you have, you go for the capacity
that you need, maybe 1,000 or 15 or
2,000 or probably bigger than that. So,
you can get a water tank where you can
easily pump your water into. So, also
that also suggests that you are supposed
to have a pumping machine where you pump
your water into it. For those of us that
don't have uh that are in places where
the power supply is not connected there,
we have to make use of the generator the
automate uh the alternative means
generator to obviously channel water
into the tank. Of course, this is a new
age where there is solar available. So,
you can get some solar uh devices that
would also help in pumping depending on
your budget also. But there's a very big
need for a water tank. It be very
tedious for you to make use of a well.
Of course, if your well is very close
by, maybe your well is quite far, it be
very tedious because these animals will
need lots of water. And I would really
advise you don't reduce the number of
water you give them because of the
stress that it takes. So what make sure
you find a convenient means that would
ensure that they will get water
continually. Also obviously they will be
needing a roof on their head. So please
don't make that mistake of leaving your
uh house to the open sky where water can
easily fall in. Even though we say these
guys needs water. We are not it doesn't
mean they need water in that sense where
the rain is always on them. They need a
place where whenever rain is falling
they can be under. They don't need water
all the time. They need water at some
certain time. So please you need to be
informed that you need a roof. And for
us right here, this roof was uh this is
not the new one. You know, this this uh
iron sheet you see here is uh the used
one. Of course, when you are running a
farm, you want to make use of the
cheapest way to go about things as I
already revealed in a video already. So,
you want to make use of the cheapest way
and you can see uh the way we did this
using the bamboos and everything. So,
make sure you uh do what works for you
and do what works for your budget. But
this is one of the basic grammar. You
need a roof on the head of your
piece. Also, you'll be making use of
buckets obviously to mix your feeds. Uh
the broom, the packa and all those many
things. Those are some of the things you
need to have. The shovel. You need a
shovel. The what you use to mix your
feed. All those things are basic
requirements you should have while
starting your farm. And you want to also
make sure you have uh all the
disinfectants that you will make use of
to ensure the right bio security on your
farm. So these are basic requirements
you know basic meaning the most the
things that you cannot afford but you
must have on your farm. So please uh if
you're planning to start your home pig
farm these are some of the things you
should look out for to start your farm
you should look out to getting them on
your farm. I really hope this has really
helped you and has really inspired you.
If you know you enjoy this video, click
on the like button and uh give give us a
thumbs up. And if you are yet to
subscribe, you can subscribe. Enure sure
you subscribe for lots of great quality
content on profitable pig farming. Thank
you very much. Bye-bye.